with more donald trump jr you know it i
i'm not a big
social media guy anymore believe it or
not i i we tweet out information that we
do on my website et cetera
but you know my the old days of fighting
jimmy kimmel and alec baldwin have died
for me i kind of
began to live my life again not for me
sean i was just going to say but not for
you
i was reading your twitter account you
are engaged in every single solitary
issue now
in this country like never before
the reality is someone has to do it sean
that's the problem you know we have
people in the republican party who are
just not willing to engage you know they
speak
you know incredibly well in front of
nice groups of republicans but
when they get to d.c when there's
pressure they're not
willing to stand up to an adverse media
that's functioning as the marketing arm
of the democrat party
me i don't have that problem i like to
engage and if someone has to do it it
might as well be me i'm willing to do
that it you know that doesn't come
uh you know free of the sticks and
arrows that i get from the other side
but it's worth it because we have to
point out these lies i did this
last summer when i wrote the book
liberal privilege if you look at what i
said in that book
literally all of it is coming true we
saw it all the media
lied about it because they wanted to
paint joe biden as though he's this you
know moderate joe he's not going to ban
fracking he's not going to do all these
things
but he isn't and whether he's in control
or not is also debatable
but we said very early on that the
people that are controlling the democrat
party
are going to make these decisions they
are going to be bad for americans
they are going to you know bend the knee
to china
and you can see based on tucker's last
segment we're doing a little bit more
than bending the knee to china
yeah okay between oh and they're trying
to pressure south korea to give another
seven
billion dollars to the iranian muellers
i don't think many people
in the news have been following the fake
news industry have been following that
or do they seem to care that john kerry
was undermining your father's foreign
policy
with back channel negotiations with
iranians that
that went unnoticed i guess if john
kerry's name was
uh general flynn it might be taken a
little differently
the reality is is every time the left
gets power
they overreach there's never been a
major political party that has
ever gone this hard left the
consequences are predictable socialism
always fails
it leads to more poverty it leads to
every promise they make is broken
and it's just a matter how much freedom
we lose in the meantime
they seem to be going for all of it in
record time
without question sean and that's because
there's no natural pushback
the republicans aren't willing to do it
they've shown that over the decades they
just rather lose gracefully i guess
that's
not really a plan that i would go with
but it's what they've done
donald trump has shown that you don't
have to do that you can actually push
back
we don't have an easy fight we don't
have a level playing field
you have multi-trillion dollar
industries between the mainstream media
and big tech doing whatever they can to
destroy the republican party
look at the difference in the handling
of governor desantis versus andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo gets emmys for sending your
grandmother to your nursing home to her
death
okay governor desantis got more hell in
florida
for keeping beaches open for keeping
beaches open
with social distancing and masks then
andrew cuomo got for executive orders
sending people into nursing homes to die
when we knew
sending the sick and elderly back into
nursing home was a susceptible
population and people would get hurt
governor desantis gets more hell for
various decisions for taking on the
press
than andrew cuomo does for having
credible accusations of sexual
harassment
and other harassment there is a double
standard that's out there
i think that people in america see it
which is why the mainstream media's
approval ratings is almost as low as
congress's
but until we have more people that are
willing to step up
and tell the truth and speak to the
american people uh you know
we're a little bit at a loss uh and it's
ridiculous and you see what's going on
1.9 trillion dollars you articulated so
many of those points well
the only problem is that almost none of
it is for actual relief
it's a democrat wish list but we saw
this before i called it out in this
summer
when the democrats were trying to add
pork into the bill that my father wanted
to push in you know the kennedy center
for the arts of course they needed
you know what was it 30 million dollars
at the time and 100 million
for this we got to make sure we get a
billion dollars for illegals uh they
don't pay taxes they likely never will
they take jobs from americans but
you know let's make sure they're on the
government take maybe one day
they'll vote democrat this is asinine
and it does nothing for the american
people
you know your passion is infectious and
i will tell you this
in my opinion this america first make
america great again
keeping america strong and great is the
battle for liberty and the battle for
freedom
and that cause never ends and never goes
out of style or fashion
um and i i would imagine on sunday
your dad will be reminding people that
this is just the beginning
uh yeah no i i have a feeling he's going
to do that i mean again you know
if you're reading the room and you're
intelligent you realize that donald
trump is still the future of the
republican party
people following that america first
agenda where they can actually
fight for the hard-working men and women
of this country those people who
are being displaced by illegals those
people who are being swept aside
uh by the democrat party who's just
flagrantly ignored them for decades
donald trump is all over that i actually
love when i see
you know some of the corporate interests
around america say we're not going to
support republicans anymore good
because that means the republican party
isn't going to be bound to those
corporate interests anymore
our congressmen and our senators can
actually start
fighting for the american people the way
that donald trump did so i love
that they are making that link uh and
breaking it
because we need more of that and we need
candidates and people who will go to bat
who will go to war and fight for the
american working class
and make sure we put them first at no
other point in time in history sean
what is it was it controversial for the
leaders
of a nation to put their people first
why is it now and how do the democrats
get away with
making america last as opposed to first
it's absolutely
fine i'm so glad when people wake up to
what's going on they'll realize
it the the worst thing they've done to
me
that i see and they've done a lot of bad
things and and i said your passion is
infectious and this
i can i can hear people at home like
nodding their head i can see them in my
mind's eye
but i'll tell you what they did when
they when they sent out pink slips
to all these career job workers uh
that made us energy independent for the
first time in 75 years oh
you'll get another union job i'm like no
they won't
those jobs aren't available and that
doesn't give them a paycheck next week
you're right republicans need to fight
for every
working man and woman in this country
and that's our future
donald trump jr thank you